yeah I mean a huge problem obviously
with places like the VA is they don't
they focus a lot on physical and
treating you with pharmaceuticals and
they want to just you know pill you up
but they don't really there's not enough
focus on mental health and mental
treatment and that's what affects the
suicide rate here's a pop on the VA is
the VA is huge the biggest Medical Group
in the world probably so they have a lot
of money it's the biggest money it's the
biggest one single spending item in the
entire budget so they have all those
millions millions of dollars you know
how they split them up you have a
physical ailment so you have a broken
bone we got to put a cast in there we're
gonna set it or you have mental
something going on you can send us
psychiatrists gonna do this and do that
right there's two huge huge pots of
money
it's always a competition between the
pots of money all right
you ever look I don't it said it's easy
you have to get an operation let's do
that phrase let's do this you have to go
see the psychiatrist to do that but the
psychiatry is it like small compared
they want to see the problem and medical
doctors and in psychologists so they're
all competing competing funds right for
this huge pot of money it's a wrong way
to look at it so you get a look at the
funds with the the funds should also be
split up into a third bucket of money
and that third bucket of money should be
about twice of what the mental illness
mental counseling and all that so
whatever their budget is multiplied by
two and take that multiplication of two
out of the physical budget so the
physical budget goes down by this much
this one comes in here you know what
that pot of money is called it's this
it's called wholeness mmm it's the whole
person it's a whole person therapy it's
a whole well-being so it's called whole
body well-being that we'd go over all
and so that has to do with after you
have a broken bone or whatever you have
to go into physical therapy physical
therapy is part of whole being because
that'll be yoga that'll be massaging
that'll be a hot tub therapy out to
every room of therapy it's all the other
therapies and as I like lifestyle
lifestyle yeah it's
proper diet we want nutrition should be
in the whole person therapy yeah so
after you're fixed with a surgery with
that net NAB you're you're you're done
the metal doctor fixed yeah he did
surgery on you
he did brain surgery foot surgery bone
surgery intestinal gastrointestinal all
the other things are part of this big
physical budget budgeting then you have
a whole being which is a physical
therapy and everything after you get to
surgery plus for the mental well-being
here the psychology and lay on a couch
and do all that that doesn't cover the
yoga and doing group therapy or do
aromatherapy or do any MD MDMA or do
marijuana or do that the whole person
therapy is drum circles is is doing a
lot of stuff because that doesn't mean
matter it all contributes back and forth
between that's all interwoven yeah and
it's also spiritual hey dude if you have
your yoga dude and it's also a prayer
guys a drunk guy he does all that I'm a
ordained minister and if you gave me a
budget because somebody's getting
operated on there like in a coma for
three weeks and I got operated on hair
that now they had to go to psychiatrist
you're missing a whole other part of
that I could have them talking to me for
you know an hour a week and I'll fix
everything in between that psychiatrists
never going to talk about and in a
medical doctors never going to know
about and I bring it all together in the
middle I'm talking about nutrition I
talk about intellectual stimulation of
that gnat and get you fired up I'm
talking about hey man let's just go sit
in a hot tub into some aromatherapy flow
bit and let's have a talk what was the
last book you read let's talk about that
book what did that book mean to you and
where does it go so it's my psychology
and it's not setting a bone I'm doing
everything in between that makes you a
whole person
yeah they don't know nutrition is huge
it's huge massive bigger than mental and
physical yeah nutrition you mean you are
you literally you are what you eat in
mindful of Valor I can do all of that
I'm gonna talk about your nutrition I'm
gonna talk about your spirituality
intellectuality I'm talking about your
sexuality
because your sexual well-being is also
part of your whole being and what are
you up to man what's going on how can
you that dude was not something 108 you
know what's going on with your marriage
you have a boyfriend or girlfriend
what's gone there let's talk about that
for a little bit so that kind of
counseling is not psychology 101 furedi
in science and it's not mental doctor or
anything else this is a whole different
spectrum of healing yeah the well-being
of you as a whole person maintenance
you're not gonna talk about sexuality
was a metal doctor or even more
psychologist because they're just gonna
talk about the Freudian crap and open it
pit I had aa brilliant at spiritual I
wanted to talk to my priest about
freaking my last date no man that's
mindful valor man that's my that's my
room the VA doesn't fund there nobody
funds that that's why I have to have a
non-profit to get money to it'll bring
somebody in and say hey man this is
winter backyard hey there's deer over
there
I have deer in my backyard right now in
my back window they're just grazing 15
yards away from me and I find a lot of
peace with that I find peace with that
do you find peace with that let's just
talk about the deer in my backyard
mm-hmm for an hour
that's wholeness man its whole body
healing that's amazing
that's amazing I love that that's what I
do any stimulation you can have a cup of
tea in your hug mug a hug hug and we can
heal that's out the hug hug we need to
start funding that kind of stuff this
should be twice of the cycle odd
psychology budget and taken from the
physical because we'll be doing physical
therapy and whole body healing